[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je sens
vim
chaque année
[Musique]
oui
j'vais
[Musique]
tha
hayek et non
[Musique]
jamais
super ce thème
[Musique]
acheter
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
myb à gonesse
mais c'est un croiseur bois un peu parce
que j'ai tout donné ces jeunes
quel honneur et l'attaché de presse me
dis qu'on a droit à quatre cinq minutes
pas pu ça débouche c'était américains
sont très très très un fait les
québécois et stan honneur c'est pour moi
extraordinaire des tarifs ou surtout
aujourd'hui c'est vrai c'est un grand
privilège et c'est ce que je suis super
contente de vous voir si nombreux et
pour moi ça m'apporte tellement de rêve
et de bonheur que c'est moi qui va vous
applaudir
[Applaudissements]
céline ça fait longtemps qu'on vous
n'avez pas vu oui qu'est ce qui s'est
passé en fait est ce qu'on peut en avoir
la vérité est ce que la presse people on
a vu que c'est un peu disons que j'avais
besoin de temps pour moi ouais j'avais
besoin de me retrouver j'avais besoin de
me recentrer et disons que je travaille
aussi depuis quelques mois sur un gros
projet artistique aux scientifiques à
méreau
je suis appelé mieux en le disant parce
que je devais le cachet mystérieux
depuis quelques mois mais je peux pas
m'empêcher de le dire ouais c'est que on
m'a proposé de me mettre sur orbite
mais non
c'est colin matthew goss
et vous êtes prête à monter sur scène
avec la tournée européenne je suis tout
à fait prêt de remonter sur scène avec
eux je vois monter je redescende va
monter je redescends
c'est le kalliste à bernay qui a pas
besoin d'élévateurs pas besoin de monter
sur scène de ce que je peux dire que
c'est mettre tous les soirs jusqu'à
liste n'est pas nettement mettre le feu
tessin et
vous avez toujours dit depuis rené
l'amour vous a pu vraiment trouvé
l'amour mais paraît que vous avez comme
encore une main de rené même la nuit
voulu parler c'est vrai tout c'est pas
exactement ça c'est que rené de son
vivant voulait que je garde beaucoup de
choses de lui alors c'est à dire c'est
vrai que j'ai fait mouler sa main dans
du plâtre et chaque soir comme à 20
avant de monter en stage je prends je le
dis donc je fais toi tu m'aimes encore
mon amoureux né ce soir ce moteur
extraordinaire c'est vrai mais ne disons
pas que j'ai gardé les bijoux de famille
congélateur
qui sait pas c'est peut-être pas là d'un
drone il fallait pas les moules est
en tout cas ouais c'est vrai qu'avec
rené on avait souvent des joker pour
l'embêter quelquefois le taquiner jetée
thiers et nettoie tout petit peu comme
un produit sûr joly au début l'emballage
fait envie mais une fois décongelés
reste pas grand chose
[Applaudissements]
on vous a souvent souvent comparé à
quelqu'un que j'adore aussi c'est lara
fabian alors lara fabian je lui propose
aujourd'hui celle nous regardent
aujourd'hui à la caméra j'aimerais seul
de la rose et j'aimerais ça lui proposer
la raf et une fois j'aimerais ça te
proposer à du vol
c'est un mélange de duels et duos c'est
à dire que tu va choisir le morceau sur
lequel tu es le plus à l'aise et puis on
va venir ici le chanter toutes les deux
nous on m'aborde si la france si le jury
aussi aujourd'hui va pouvoir dire
laquelle des deux à l'organe le plus
développé
[Applaudissements]
dernière question puis après j'aimerais
peut-être un chroniqueur sur tellement
ému tout c'est quelque chose comme ça
vraiment incroyable là je peux vous dire
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
hallucinant vous avez accepté aucune
émission c'est quand le plus gros
caprices de diva si vous en avez une
alors moi j'ai toujours élevé mes
enfants dans le respect pile la
simplicité choix du jour naître une diva
à dire tiens comme maria carey jo est en
concert ce soir faut changer tout les v6
remet des toilettes 9 à changer la
moquette puis toute la tapisserie c'est
pas vraiment mon truc moi j'ai été élevé
dans le vieux baril de mes parents la
restaure le manioc québec et c'est sûr
que je garde dans mon coeur cette
tradition cette simplicité trop de cas
prise par contre après le show quand on
a fait deux millions de chiffre
d'affaires on prend une petite coupette
mondiale céline pas cartonné ce soit ma
biche
comprend bien quelqu'un derrière
question pour ces lignes peut-être c'est
qu'elle est allé si haut là là ça part
dans tous les sens je traîne oui peut
être florian bourges closer j'ai une
question de prestige parce que c'est
parce que depuis quelques années on
s'interroge sur votre sur votre pièce
sur sexualité entre autres on a tout
évoquer notamment votre attirance pour
les femmes éventuel est ce que vous
pouvez ici ce soir vous dire ce qu'il en
est vera disons que j'aime les gens
j'aime la demande est dès lors qu'on est
heureuse dès lors qu'on est passionné on
peut tomber amoureuse d'une personne
d'un être humain c'est pour qu'il soit
jean rhéaume ou femmes c'est la passion
qu'on échange en sang alors j'ai une
bonne que sur vous ou bien faire qu'on
fait pas une bonne nouvelle pour vous
collomb vous dansiez ghana qui vous
regardent et des yeux je n'ai jamais vu
ça de ma vie c'était leur enfant c'est
le monsieur caire
c'est de faire un groupe est parce que
moi
[Applaudissements]
les et messieurs que céline mon corps la
vraie céline mais ce qui même en dehors
de céline céline s'appelle sébastien
costume de vous dire quoi céline
séville par là et c'était un chai dans
toute la france et qui a même élu
résidence ton pavé gâte c'est ringard
mais à rennes on peut aller vous voir et
je peux vous dire que le talent d'un
préfet même vous dire quelque chose dans
les loges gibbons vous parlez vous venez
de rennes et vous aviez déjà l'accent
québécois vous avez déclenché dans un
personnage si je suis invité quelque
part du matin au soir chez ans céline
exactement c'est l'insee ces personnages
célèbres lada ont échoué ou un truc
alors à dernier parce que pourquoi
n'avait il peu moqueur et joué depuis
longtemps c'est jay vous quittiez leur
enseignement exactement à l'incroyable
talent c'est
un coup de coeur et oui et non c'est lui
qui gère maintenant et j'en profite pour
remercier tous mes musiciens qui
m'accompagnent mon orchestre
philharmonique génération va se
reconnaître ce qu'on fait le show d'une
heure et demie tous les tubes destinés
dans la rue dans toute la france et le
monde entier
beaucoup plus illusion merci
non merci
[Applaudissements]
ce
cas l'émotion
[Applaudissements]
mariah carey les stars américaines va
venir ici je sais pas quoi faire